my father immigrated to this country
legally from Colombia and I hope that
he's looking down rather than very proud
that I'm sitting the table but the
United States regarding Hispanics I
think school choice critical issue
you've spoken a lot about it lately that
it's the civil rights issue of our time
they've got to be true for the span of
community too many Hispanic children
today are trapped in substandard or
failing government schools we need to
empower their families empower those
parents with educational choice so they
can go to school that will serve them
well many of them Catholic and
evangelical schools I think this is a
winning issue for the country well thank
you so much mr. president
thank you so much for this opportunity
to dialogue with you on the priority
issues for Latino general Garza
presidents of the Liberty initiative son
of migrant farmworkers who came from a
small Township called gotta settle in
Southern Nevada Mexico my parents came
to America because they started the
promise and it was here where they
achieved the American dream
we were very motivated when you set the
tone early in your administration when
you lessen the tax burden on Latino
individuals and businesses it's so
important for Latinos to prosper in
America to have a prosperous America and
it's important to have a prosperous
America to have a prosperous Latino
community we're interdependent and we
want to see a continued activity of
deregulation that we've seen especially
in the area of health care through
telemedicine where a doctor doesn't have
to be in the same room with the patient
we've seen that during the Kovan area we
want to continue that down the road also
mr. president I remind you of a phone
call that we had not that long ago about
a month ago on the state bailouts those
debts that preceded the Kovan era should
not be considered we have to consider
our financial health physical health in
America and make sure that we lessen the
debt that we have they're passing on to
the next generation so I want to thank
you for your commitment into that and
again for I think setting a table where
we were able to unleash an economic
bonanza for the Latino community again
you know low unemployment high labor
participation rates high wage increases
home ownership again we benefited from
that jobs you see that the Hispanic
community 2 point 1 billion people back
to work already
that's right Thank You mr. president for
allowing us to be here today what an
honor to be here not only as an American
a Hispanic American you know I could
trace my family roots to this country
decades before the Pilgrims landed on
Plymouth Rock yeah yeah and and yet
hardworking Americans growing up in
poverty youngest debate kids no dad it
was through those conservative American
ideals those that you have were fighting
for every single day I was raised by
this great woman who had the
responsibility of raising eight kids by
herself no running water but through
hard work staying in school getting a
good education and taking advantage of
the American dream I'm here sitting
across the table from the president the
United States what an honor that's the
American dream thank you sir I want to
say coming from New Mexico now the third
largest energy producing state in the
country some of the most richest
producing oil fields in the world rival
emit some say maybe more than Saudi
Arabia it is because of your policy sir
that have unleashed American energy that
makes this country now energy
independence and a New Mexico that
translates into jobs and you know the
majority those jobs mr. president or
Hispanic workers they may not have a
college education or a degree but you
know what they're working in the
oilfield making $100,000 a year for
their families are able to buy home send
their kids to school by a truck that's
the American dream as all I'll let you
know for the great state of New Mexico
the people the Hispanics the largest
percentage of Hispanics of any state in
the nation we want to say thank you and
we hope that you continue with your
second administration services that you
continue to bring the American dream to
all Americans especially Hispanics
it's a big factor in New Mexico we're
giving you tremendous safety security
like never before
but the world is going up mister look up
a big chunk of it is going up in New
Mexico City I know they're very happy
about it and they appreciate national
security and public safety that big
beautiful wall but it has big gates the
people who want to enter our nation
properly legally they're able to do it
Thank You mr. president
Thank You mr. president thank you for
thank you Mario Rodriguez spanic 100
first of all as a son of a Korean
Vietnam veteran I want to thank you what
you've done for the veterans in this
country thank you so much I remember my
dad and mom complaining that it took him
so long to get an appointment with the
VA and now you have taken care of that
for them and for that we thank you we
also thank you for the opportunities
owns what you're doing on that I'm a
bill I'm building single-family homes in
Santa Ana which is the opportunity zone
and it's flourishing and we're taking
these areas that are down ridden areas
and they're gonna in the next five years
you're gonna see them flourish it's
going to be incredible what you're doing
is going to opportunity zones in this
country and one thing I would really I
can't thank you enough for what you've
tried to do for these daca recipients
you put something on the table that was
very fair I have we run a mentorship
program and I spoke to one of my mentor
mentees and she's a doc recipient and I
put on the table what you had on that
what you put your initiative that you
put forward and I said you tell me and I
don't want to forget about the politics
but you tell me if you think this is a
fair start and she said absolutely and
what was really disappointing is that
the Democrats are using these young
adults as political pawns and that's
just totally unacceptable in this
country
and now as you know we start the process
all over again we're gonna take care of
dhaka
they're not gonna have anything to worry
about but we did have a deal in Dhaka
and the Democrats decided not to make
the deal it was a very very fair deal
really what really was very
disheartening thank you very much very
much Thank You mr. president good
afternoon
Alfredo were teas presidency of Java
craters Network an organization that was
started by Bernie Marcus one of our
greatest entrepreneurs stories are the
Home Depot an amazing amazing Patriot
and entrepreneur we're proud to have
create an organization over the past 10
years that literally went from zero to
over five hundred thousand small
business owners in this country as you
correctly identified pretty much from
the first day of your presidency small
businesses not only the backbone of our
country but the backbone of our
communities
just before kovat they were really
experiencing some of the best broke they
had ever seen Hispanics in particular
we're seeing some of the best growth
they had also seen from from a small
business perspective in general with the
highest you know some of the highest
home ownership on record as you know
lowest unemployment in history
it really has had been an amazing run I
know we had sold Lipnick ovid but as
huge is correctly identified over two
million jobs in the last two months were
created that were actually Hispanic and
so we're very excited I'm very excited
to here to be here also from a personal
perspective I am the son of I am a proud
American of Mexican descent I'm the son
of two immigrants my dad was a tailor my
mom was a housekeeper so to go from
literally picking trash and cleaning
toilets to sitting here having this
conversation with you only this country
could this happen so try to be here
the President of Mexico and then he we
had a tremendous dialogue going
we're working very well with Mexico as
you know yes a lot of people didn't
think that was going to happen and it
happened beyond anybody's expectations
so it was really good it's a great day
well thank you it just strikes me Steve
talked about school choice Daniel talked
about deregulation John talked about the
energy independence
Mario talked about Opportunity Zones you
just finished talking about jobs this is
this is what you're fighting for this is
your vision and to have seen it executed
and implemented and the results over the
last three and a half years is really
remarkable so thank you all for being
here and for being such warriors for the
cause of Liberty
thank you for hello mr. president my
name is Eduardo velocity I am an actor
and a filmmaker I am from Mexico but I
work in both Mexico and United States so
I produce films and our mission is to
make films that hopefully not only will
entertain but hopefully will make a
difference in people's lives because we
know how media input infrastop people
think thank you for your leadership and
in defending your work as you know
Mexicans the majority of Mexicans
support the right to life and thank you
for defending life in America and in
Latin America without a doubt you are
the best the greatest pro-life president
in the history of United States thank
you for that thank you for your
leadership in the u.s. NCI I'm from
Mexico some of the very proud to one
having last night and and I'm very is a
win win for Mexico and other states but
I'm convinced that very soon very soon
Mexico will be the number one partner
trading of the United States god bless
you and let's make Mexico
America America and Mexico pray together
there's a bakery into a jet they can't
reach them mr. president what can I tell
you I'm so blessed to be here in the
most prosperous country in the world the
greatest country in the world and we're
so blessed to have you as our leader as
we continue to build this country and
they could continue to make it the most
prosperous nation in the world
I'm Bobby Knight my third generation I'm
CEO and president of 40 Foods Inc a
multi-billion dollar company with
facilities all over the United States
and Spain we have about 4,500 employees
before my dad phoned me of the avoid the
question rate for the family and these
people we didn't be happy back to work
because we never stop never stop working
we doubled our efforts and I asked the
guys and gals I said hey this is tough
and they said look if we don't do it
nobody will and they said percenter is
it calenus my grandfather left Spain at
18 years old on the steamship in 1904
with a lot of other European people who
the economy over there was not the most
prosperous in the world so they came to
me came to the United States did
quarterly go in 1936 he established he
was importing products in Spain that was
a Spanish Civil War
that fried up he stabbed his boy who's
1:20 Street in Manhattan and that time
it was a butter of an egg pocket now you
have boule and all these great
restaurants and all of them marvelous
things in New York but anyway we're all
over the United States and the United
States after Mexico is the largest
Hispanic country in the world by 2050
there will be one third of the
population prosperity is what we need to
faith in God prosperity to work hard and
it's a bill you are an incredible
builder and that I tell our people our
family look we're just beginning because
as the country grows as a Hispanic
community grows we continue to grow and
that is a the American dream that's
that's our success so we'll be speaking
outside in a little while in the Rose
Garden and I look forward to seeing you
out there media and thank you very much
reaction to the Supreme Court rulings
today mr. president well the rulings
were basically starting all over again
sending everything back down to the
lower courts and to start all over again
so from a certain point satisfied from
another point of not satisfied because
frankly this is a political witch-hunt
placement which nobody's ever seen
before it's a pure witch-hunt it's a
hoax
just like the Muller investigations are
hoaxes that I wanted and this is another
hoax this is purely political I win at
the federal level and we won very
decisively and so they send it into New
York and you know what's going on in New
York everyone's leaving this turned out
to be a hellhole they better do
something about it because people are
leaving New York there's a political
witch-hunt
it just continues it's been from before
I got here when Obama and Biden and
everybody else was spying on my campaign
illegally they were illegally spying on
my campaign and it's a very grave crime
it's a previous political crime in the
history of our country and I want to
thank the Hispanic Americans for being
with me great people thank you very much
let's go
you